Vitamin B17 retoxic so B17 is a big Dylan also known as Leia trill I
Have heard conflicting reports
I don't think there needs to be any conflicting reports
Vitamin B17 can be toxic in high doses
There's no question about that
Anything could be toxic, right? But I mean, yeah, if we take the whole bottle of something other than I guess could be toxic
But B17 is different. It could be toxic and relatively lower doses
Beating if you had if you took the whole bottle of your B17 capsules of
Apricot power be even the hundred milligram B17 you'd probably be in the hospital getting your stomach pumped
If you took the 500 milligram
Tablets the whole bottle you'd be definitely be in the hospital getting your stomach pumped
Um
Yes, it can be toxic. I think the most that I've ever recommended anybody to take up the B17 500 milligrams is three per day
Um, could it be toxic at that dose? No, it's not gonna be toxic at that dose can it stay in your system and build up and be toxic over time? No
Um, no, it's a water soluble nutrient and it will flush out of your system
Um, if you took three of them at one time on an empty stomach and I only weigh a hundred pounds could it be toxic?
No
Could you get a tummy ache from it? I think you get tummy ache from anything
So it's probably not even the substance that you're going to tummy ache from it's probably the capsule
So in in the doses that I've ever recommended it's not going to be toxic
Um, I would say that there are conflicted reports out there that basically aren't
Dissied B17 as a therapy say that nobody should ever take it because it's a toxic substance blah blah
That's just nonsense
um
It's perfectly safe to use in the right dosage
um, and uh, it can be a wonderful cancer killer for people who test well on it
So we don't have that many people on it, but um, we've had good success with it